pour confectionner ces jeans français il
faut compter sur ses employés qui
maîtrisent les arts du métier
si sur des alliés incontournables dans
le procédé des machines très gourmandes
en énergie
si c'est une étape qui est très
énergivore dans le processus de tissage
de France les factures de gaz et
d'électricité ont explosé on avait en
2021 400000 euros d'énergie sur 4
millions de chiffre d'affaires on va
dire 10% en 2022 ce 400.000 euros est
devenu 900000 euros c'est à dire presque
25% du chiffre d'affaires et en 2023 au
prix d'aujourd'hui ce serait 2 millions
d'euros donc c'est tellement énorme que
ce n'est pas possible
pour réduire ses immenses dépenses
l'entreprise a dû ralentir le rythme
pendant tout le mois de septembre les
activités ont été suspendues le lundi et
le vendredi une stratégie qui a permis
de diminuer la consommation mais qui a
aussi eu des impacts sur le personnel de
chômage partiel ça peut faire du bien
économiquement mais ça désorganise ça
demande beaucoup d'agilité beaucoup de
souplesse à toute l'équipe ça peut faire
peur aussi donc c'est jamais de getter
de cœur qu'on fait ce choix là mais on a
expliqué à toute l'équipe pourquoi on
faisait ça pour notre avenir
il n'y a pas que les entreprises qui
sont frappées de plein fouet par
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie les
villes et municipalités à travers le
pays voit aussi les impacts sur leur
budget ici à Varengeville dans l'Est de
la France on a par exemple décidé de
réduire la consommation énergétique et
ce avant même que le gouvernement
français fasse des recommandations à ce
sujet
la communauté de 3700 habitants a
accéléré un virage vert qui avait déjà
été prévu dans cette ville industrielle
en transformation il fallait absolument
limiter les dépenses énergétiques sans
quoi c'est le tiers de la capacité
annuelle d'investissement qui aurait
disparu le contexte géopolitique et la
crise du gaz russe
ont contribué à nous faire accélérer
dans les prises de décision a
complètement changé nos plans
d'investissement pour réaliser un
maximum d'économies le plus tôt possible
parce que l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie nous contraints énormément
budgétairement parlant si on n'agit pas
pour éviter le gaspillage la Ville
entend mieux isolé certaines saisies
comme ce centre sportif cet éclairage
qui est très énergivore dès cette année
on y changera ses vieux panneaux
lumineux pour les remplacer par des
landesl qui consomment beaucoup moins
donc on passera sur de l'éclairage blanc
moderne dans l'immédiat les autorités
ont déjà réalisé d'importantes économies
d'énergie baisse du chauffage dans les
édifices municipaux et fermeture de
l'éclairage public à partir de minuit
le jour se lève à peine quand Arnaud
Huin entreprend sa journée il a de
nombreux clients à visiter pendant sa
tournée j'ai jamais vu un tel engouement
pour le bois l'entreprise pour laquelle
il travaille vend des granulés de bois
utilisés pour se chauffer vu la demande
en un an la valeur d'un sac comme
celui-ci est passé de 4 à plus de 10
euros
les bonnes vieilles bûches de bois ont
elles aussi connu un regain de
popularité on produit actuellement 600
stères par semaine et cela ne suffit pas
encore pour alimenter tous les foyers
donc on est obligé de rationner pas plus
de 6 terres par client les clients qui
commandent actuellement seront livrés
que en début d'année 2023
certains clients pour rencontrer sur une
bonne réserve pour se chauffer cet hiver
c'est comme des lingots d'or chaque bus
est comme un lingot cette année il a
doublé ses achats de bois question de
moins avoir recours au gaz dont dépend
aussi sa résidence c'est l'année où on a
consommé le moins de gaz et on a payé
probablement 50% de plus que l'année
dernière que les années précédentes donc
oui oui c'est vraiment exposé
dans les locaux de tissage de France ce
mois-ci les activités ont repris du
lundi au vendredi mais ici on sait que
l'industrie n'est pas à l'abri d'autres
défis nous l'intérêt de bien s'y
préparer
certaines machines énergivores seront
changées les systèmes de chauffage mieux
adaptés on n'aura jamais investi
collectivement autant dans les économies
d'énergie qu'aujourd'hui l'énergie
augmente quelque part c'est un peu
malheureux d'attendre d'être au pied du
mur pour investir sur des solutions de
bon sens pour l'environnement et puis
même pour le pour le pour l'aspect
financier dans le secteur public ou
privé c'est une voie que beaucoup en
Europe semble maintenant emprunter il
s'est rafale